I think Hillsdale County is magical
I do think back to my freshman year in
that summer that I stayed in Hillsdale
and every single day a memory that I
have is just kind of whimsical like it
was beautiful every day and everyone's
happy and kind I think that people in
Hillsdale are hard-working
they're dedicated and they have a sense
that they're working towards something
like bigger than themselves which I
definitely think it's something that
people run the college definitely tapped
into you as well the college itself is a
great community and the county itself is
a great community
they're both centered around interesting
ideas
I can always travel to see the ocean I
can travel to see the mountains but this
is where all the important things are
I'm from California originally and born
in Santa Maria pull up in Escondido the
move to San Diego I am from Virginia
Virginia Beach is where I grew up I now
live in Hillsdale when I showed up I was
contending on getting my degree and then
moving back to California as I was here
longer though there was a feeling that
we have here in Hillsdale that we didn't
have in San Diego and it was the
camaraderie of being here everyone wants
to know your story everyone wants to
know how they can help you or relate to
you I had my first daughter Chloe and
once I had this little baby that I was
responsible for I thought I want to stay
in hell still to raise her I can give
her everything here that's important
just by staying here I actually after I
graduated I didn't really have anywhere
to stay and this couple that I had
become friends with from waitressing
they let me stay with them and you don't
find that other places everyone's just
very hospitable and kind and it's really
genuine it's really genuine
I met Derek basically right after I
graduated college I was born and raised
in Michigan my kind of great-grandfather
started a shoe store with his two sons
my dad worked in the shoe store
I worked in my father's still are
growing up my dad's family has been in
the area since the eighteen forties they
think my mom's family 1870s or something
you know who your neighbors are you know
the person who gives you your coffee in
the morning and you gain an experience
through that that I think is sometimes a
little bit lost in places that are much
busier I opened up my own sandwich shop
here in 2016 in one dynamic like oh I
think I know Hillsdale College and then
be put you know within a five-minute
walk of campus selling something that
everybody loves and so when I work to
check her records I thought I knew a lot
of college kids and then I came and open
and they we were just reflecting the
other day I like how many like students
that we just like know their order like
before they come in you see community
members at basketball games and
professors living in town
copies jobs the mission I feel is the
same they want what's best for this
community there's a lot of opportunity
there to work together and to do things
obviously the college's mission is a lot
more concrete and tangible but they they
stand by you know their
people in Hillsdale are strangely
similar I'd say that the college in the
town are like a lot more like than they
care to admit on either side and so like
I think that's cool and probably what
makes the two entities work well
together
[Music]